foreign
when did it start
um so my only guess is when I was four
my dad died in a car accident so very um
unexpectedly but that's a big thing
Megan it's not like a it's a big thing
what up what up this is John with the Dr
John deloney show
the greatest mental health and marriage
and relationship in the parenting
podcast ever in the history of digital
media
is about
I'm just gonna keep expanding this make
it cooler than it actually is
um so glad that you're with us and hey
here's the deal I'm not talking to
anybody I'm talking with folks and I'm
so grateful that you pulled up a seat to
the table and we're just going to figure
out Life as we move forward together if
you want to be on this show give me a
call at
1-844-693-3291 and I hesitate to do this
um but it does help out the show so if
you will
if you find something of value in the
show if you will share it with somebody
if you'll send it to somebody if you
will go on the internet and I honestly
don't know how to do what I'm about to
tell you to do but if you could leave a
a five-star review that would be dope if
there's a two or three star review that
you feel please email Kelly directly and
don't do it in Stars be a grown-up and
just tell her how bad the show is like
with words but if you want to see how
good it is be a child and do it with uh
just five stars how about that but the
reviews do help and the subscriptions if
you subscribed it does help it helps
everything helps move it up in the
algorithms which sends it to more people
which for me ultimately helps more
people get the help and care they need
it helps us all feel a little less crazy
to know
we're all in this together so thank you
so so much for riding with us all right
let's go to uh Megan in Spring Hill
Kansas my favorite state what's up Megan
hello it's good to talk to you Dr John
it's good to talk to you how are you
I'm good how is the land of uh waving
grain
well I will tell you it's great out here
but you as well as the rainbow team I
guess we're we're probably just not good
enough for you because you guys never
come back to Kansas City
dude Kansas dis here's the thing I put
up some internet post recently where I
was like
do whatever you got to do to change your
life like in sell stuff
um you know have hard conversations move
to Kansas if you have to and the
internet took that and they said it was
like a Diss and it's not I think you can
I've got family in Kansas and you can
have a killer life there for one one
millionth of the price of having
A hurried psychotic life in Manhattans
anyway I'm all Kansas I'm gonna
intentionally plan an event there in the
coming months is that cool
uh that would be great I'll be there
you'll come okay well uh in fact we'll
get your info and we'll hook you up
whenever we make it happen okay oh
we're gonna do this we're gonna party in
Kansas it's gonna be my my uh apology
tour to Kansas all right so that's not
what you called what's up
um so I was calling um hopefully this is
one of your lighter calls I am calling
to ask how can I control my control
issues
kind of
um I guess a longer explanation
um kind of a
a wide range of answers there but I feel
like it has gotten a lot worse since
I've had kids I have two girls a four
year old and a six month old and I just
feel like every single thing in my in
our life in our family's life I have to
control I need like I control our
schedule in our calendar and
um so my husband travels for work he's
one of those Royal rotors I heard on one
of your podcasts before um yes so you I
know that you know all about that life
he's home like one day a week
um if we're lucky we get just over 24
hours with him but
um so like even on that one day a week
it's like I don't
I don't just like take a step back and
like relax and ah okay he's here like
we're a family we can just relax on this
say no way it's like oh by the way this
day is scheduled minute by minute even
though your hearings are only day with
you
um and like even down to things such as
when he is home I find myself like I
have to drive the car because I don't
know which route you're going to take
and I'm not gonna like that or
um just anything that we do have planned
I need to know like the who's the when
the where the why the how behind it all
I just feel like I need to be in control
of absolutely everything which leaves no
like room for just breathing and just
letting life happen and I will tell you
my husband's completely opposite he's
the kind of guy that says um I think
there's a quote that's like life happens
when you're too busy planning for it
something like that so how do I you know
why he can say that
because he's with you
I was gonna say because I can control
everything that's right and my guess is
he is somebody in his family possibly
his mom did the same thing or it was
very similar
um yeah but he can do that that's my
attitude come what may dude let's figure
it out because I have a wife that takes
care of all the crap you know what I
mean and so that's that's the definition
of privilege just to be like what why
are you worried about that well somebody
has to feed the kids right so yeah I
don't want you to feel insane
um this started a long long time ago
when did it start
um so my only guess is when I was four
my dad died in a car accident so very um
unexpectedly okay I just smiled
um not because your dad passed away so I
want people watching this on YouTube and
I'd be like this guy's got no soul I'm
smiling because the way you framed it
was like I I've done some deep digging
and I dropped a couple of big gulps
walking out of a supermarket once and
you're like I I went looking and um the
only thing I can come up with is my dad
died of course uh yeah I mean that's the
only thing I can come probably right but
that's a big thing Megan it's not like a
it's a big thing yes how it would tie
into needing to control everything I
guess necessarily here's what here's
what I would guess I am completely
making this up and you and I can spend
three or four hours together just
hanging out in Kansas and we can we
could go deeper okay my guess is
when your dad passes away
that's huge especially when you're four
but what's equally if not more
um
maddening insane besides the grief and
loss your whole world is over at that
point and you're gonna have to have a
new world
but it's the adults in your life whose
worlds also explode
yes and my guess is was your mom in the
scene back then
no no no no was your mom how did she
handle this
um
I mean looking back I
we're not a family that shares our
emotions period so I remember we went to
counseling I think
um I mean gosh looking back I don't
honestly remember I know that my sister
went
separately she was seven years old at
the time and then we all went together I
don't think that I went all by myself
but I I could totally be wrong on that
um so nobody was counseling I don't
really remember talking much about it
other than in counseling um right so
listen so repressed uh repressed that
sounds so dramatic
you've been parenting yourself since you
were four years old
and four-year-olds don't have the
capacity for words like sad they don't
have words like heartbroken like what
what just our whole world is in ashes
why why does Mom keep disappearing
yeah mom is radioactive but she won't
tell me she doesn't have the words to
say and it's not I'm not begging on mom
mom didn't have a skill set either her
whole world exploded but
mom didn't know that the greatest gift
she could give me as a four-year-old was
to hug me so tight and say I miss Daddy
so much
yeah because you miss Daddy too and you
would have not been more depressed you
would have felt less insane
okay and so your four-year-old body has
been grabbing for control because that's
all it had and you've been grabbing it
for a long time and how old are your
kids
they're six months and four or six month
old and a four-year-old
your body has a pin in four years old
and it would not surprise me if you have
not been on an escalating control uh
your grip has been tightening on your
world over the past six to nine to ten
months is that fair yep
your body is gearing up for this moment
when everything explodes again
yep it remembers this and you're married
to a railroad guy yeah I know right so a
lot of things I do talk about that I
know but like but that a lot of the
control the world of railroaders is not
set up for human existence
yeah it's set up to extrapolate the last
ounce of soul out of somebody in
exchange for money in the future a good
retirement that's what that job is for
yeah exactly not designed to have a
family to be a Cornerstone of a
community to eat to have any sort of
Health right any job that says this is
gonna suck so bad I'll give your wife a
full retirement is already saying up
front we don't care about you that's a
whole other podcast though right so
that's the world you're in and so your
control needs are are real somebody's
got to feed those kids and even when
your husband's off you know this he's a
zombie
and he has to this isn't like a he's got
he's got to do something to relax too
right he's got to have hobbies and be
able to go outside and move around
otherwise he'll just die
um yeah so there's two things going on
here and this is just a quick flyby
right because this is something you and
I can spend more time with
yeah
at some point you're gonna have to feel
those feelings you've never felt
I feel like I don't know how to go about
that because I I listen to you for since
day one and I've heard you say um you
know like write your feelings Journal
your feelings feel your feelings and
I've tried to journal them but honestly
after like one or two feelings or
thoughts I just I'm like okay yep I'm
fine and then it doesn't come for
I don't know it's a very long period
that's fantastic here's where I start
is I identify the behavior that is that
is maladaptive I identified the behavior
in my life that is not serving me or the
people I love very well
okay for me it's grabbing food for you
it's when you you start getting more
controlly and more angsty and more
right
yep that's the moment that you sit down
and write your feelings down if you just
Bebop in on a normal Saturday morning
dude your body's better than that it's
it's shove that crap so far down under
so many layers of performance and joy
and smiles and dancing and by the way
you don't have to have some big
cathartic you don't have to replay the
wreck none of that kind of stuff
okay it's it's not that it's it's simply
this
your husband comes home and he's like
hey we're all going to dinner tonight
and you instantly your heart rate goes
up yep it's I have a plan and we're
eating here I've been thawing meat since
four o'clock and you just Walt it yeah
that right there is what we're gonna
work on
so we're gonna go in our bedroom for
five minutes after he just announces
that and you're gonna talk to him ahead
of time and say I'm trying to learn
about my body
and you're going to ask yourself this
one question what is my body trying to
protect me from
and just answer that question
and probably it's just gonna it's gonna
wind all the way down to
we control about nothing in this world
yes about nothing
right
yes and you know more than anybody in
the world
that we can have all the safety
protocols and do all the right things
and some drunk driver is going to hit us
and it's all over
yeah but he was actually he was the
drunk driver but he was okay or somebody
we love is gonna go do something stupid
and get themselves killed yes right
which I actually didn't learn until that
he was intoxicated until geez Louise
um less than 15 years ago which tells me
you've got a family culture of Secrets
and secrets destroy people
yeah from the inside out my guess is you
might have passed that along I brought
that to your marriage
and it might not be Secrets if you're
seeing somebody else although it might
but it's probably secrets of
um how angry and raged out you get at
the railroad how frustrated you are with
your husband being gone all the time and
you love him and want to support him but
God I wish I had a regular husband at a
regular job in a regular life like all
and you bottle those things up and you
keep them and keep them and keep them in
the way your body has chosen to handle
that sort of
um compression is through control mine
is through eating and distraction
my wife is through control
um some of my friends are through
alcohol or weed some of my friends are
um from flirting and hanging out with
people they're not married to right so
it's all across the board everybody
deals some is it's workaholism they just
work and work and work and try to outrun
it
it's sitting down and saying okay this
is what I'm feeling right now
okay and being able to say okay I had
plans
I do want to go out actually
let's do it or like my wife will do to
me she'll say
I would love to go out
but it's not in our budget we didn't
budget for it I do have this food set
and I don't want to waste it and I
really would like I need a quiet night
at home
and I say great and that's different
than control
that's being able to express your needs
which comes after being able to feel
stuff does that make sense
it does yes thank you so here's what I
want you to consciously think of when
you start tightening up
consciously this is a the practice pull
your shoulders down as low as they'll go
and open your hands because almost
always your hands will clench up yeah
open your hands and then go need five
and go in your room and write it down my
guess is you may end up not needing to
talk to somebody not to promise not to
go process the trauma from that long ago
but my guess is y'all are going to have
to learn new skills on how to be married
that you didn't get growing up
yeah
is that fair
that's fair
do you want your husband to quit his job
he won't he will not and the thing is
you know he will be like oh yeah I'm
home this week and he'll be in town for
a week and they'll be like oh by the way
next week I have to go just two hours
away which is for the railroad is right
down the street I'm like oh of course
you do because you know you got to be
home for one week and you got to be
here's here let me see do you want him
to quit his job
foreign
yeah okay hey here's the thing for so
long you haven't said what you need
because you couldn't because it didn't
matter
yeah and you've got to get to a place
where you're able to say here's what I
need
and it might not be I need you to quit
your job but it might be I need my
husband
yeah I need my friend I need my lover I
need my co-parent and this job is in the
way of that
yes otherwise
you're going to end up in a big pile of
resentment
yeah
you are and somebody at Whole Foods is
going to wink at you or help you with a
carton and you're going to get their
number and also you're gonna be Off to
the Races or he is going to realize that
you have a distance between the two of
you and he's going to text somebody
right you see that's how that happens
let's back out of that thing you just
said I know I know Megan
you've got to back out of this thing and
say here's what I need
okay I need you and then we're gonna
backfill that and it's again it's a
skill to practice and I don't think
you've ever said your needs out loud
yeah is that true
that's true I mean maybe maybe starting
to now
um yeah but you wait too long if you
start announcing your needs on the back
end of a of a failed control attempt
it's War
so if he comes out here here's what that
sounds like um so if he comes home and
says
hey let's just forget it let's go out to
eat I'm taking everybody out to dinner
yeah and in your head you've been
preparing for a meal all day you know
that kid number one has been whining all
day and I'm not taking that one out in
public and this one's got the the
rockets diarrheas and I'm annoyed and
I'm
and he just comes home and announces
that right yes then you start seething
and you clinch your hands up and you
clinch your jaw up and you start to get
a little bit louder with the cabinets
and then he's like why are you so mad I
want to take you out to dinner because
he's really trying to help and you say
we us I've already got stuff started and
he's like I know I just want to be there
for you and then you snap
yeah I need you that's not needs that's
War
yeah the needs are the week before when
you say hey and this is this is what a
gift my wife gave me when you just Waltz
in and announce you're taking the family
out to dinner you just have inserted
yourself into an entire family ecosystem
that you are away from
yes that makes me feel X
yeah so if you want to go out to eat
would you text me as soon as you think
of it during the day and I can text you
back and say I've already got dinner
ready do you wanna you still want to go
you see what I'm saying we've had to
create a new algorithm and really at the
end of the day my goal was to help I was
trying to help her out and I learned the
best way to help her out is to ask her
what she needs and her best way to get
the help she needs is to be honest with
me about what she actually needs that's
totally different than me trying to save
the day see what I'm saying yeah
definitely and I can see that in our
our relationship as well yes so no more
war but all that starts with
is your control helping
no I think it's I just try it it just
like grows yes like I get a little bit
of control here so I need to
um control you know the next thing and
then the next thing the next thing and
that's nothing's actually under control
everything's really just on fire right
now yes but your grip is so tight that
you feel like you got it you're getting
dragged behind a car pulling you down
the highway and you're like I got this
and everyone's like you clearly don't
have this right so yeah here's the
here's the um I say this a lot and I'll
end with this
the things that kept us safe and Alive
as a kid are the things that often are
disruptive to our adult lives
this worked for you because it had to
because mom went in a black hole of
grief and may have never come out
because y'all went to a couple of
counseling sessions and then you learned
really carefully really quickly that our
family keeps Secrets some things we
don't talk about
and you felt crazy and then that little
body that little girl said we're on our
own we got to control everything because
that's our path forward
and now you have your own little kids
and you realize you can't control
anything
you have your husband who works for a
disastrous industry in terms of how it
treats people
and you realize I've lost him too
and then you start thinking well here's
what I can control I can control that
relationship I can control this I can
control how organic the spinach is
whatever and you end up winding yourself
up in a straight jacket
[Music]
you're worth a peaceful life
you're worth a marriage that works
you're worth not cheating on somebody
you're worth kids being able to laugh
you're worth walking through life with
Your Hands Held open because anything
else is an illusion
whoo let me know how that goes I want to
hear your progress on that Megan and uh
I'll keep our listeners notified thank
you so much for being brave we'll be
right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spinning
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step
and when you're facing problems or
challenges in life it's way too easy to
get stuck in that anxious spiral of Doom
I've been there but when you learn how
to stop that cycle and start taking
ownership of your life that's when
you're free and that's what therapy can
help you do it gives you the tools you
need to do the problem solving in your
own life and that's why I love better
help better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist it's more
affordable than in-person therapy plus
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours if you're ready to get
the tools that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's thrown at you therapy
can help visit betterhelp.com deloni to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com deloney
all right we are back okay let's take a
quick second
Sarah and Jenna what happened you're a
huge Award winners your award-winning
filmmaker yes tell me about it we are
now award-winning filmmakers
congratulations tell me all about it so
we did the Nashville 48 Hour film
project
um so you had 48 hours to you got your
genre and then you wrote it you shot it
you edited it and then you got it in
Sunday night
um so we did that and we had our awards
for it last night and they had four
screenings
um ours was in group a and it was span
voted and each group you got a vote for
your top three favorite and so we won
our group a award screening
congratulations way to go everybody yeah
it was awesome look at this caliber of
talent
Kelly knows when she's like I don't know
what's happening here I'm gonna hire the
best
well done Kelly I see what you did there
congratulations Sarah that's awesome
um you guys were the heartbeats behind
this thing so very cool man I'm super
thrilled for you that's so rad two of
the five of us have talent every Nate's
pretty good too Nate's pretty good
they're on the on the tubes all right
let's go ah you're getting there Ben
you're getting there I'm just kidding I
don't care hey uh you're better than I
am that's that's for
for that's for sure let's go to Seth in
Tampa what's up Seth
hey good morning John how are you I'm
good my brother what's up
there's some guidance in some direction
I'm at a uh a point in my life that one
I never thought I'd be in and two I have
no idea how to navigate through so I was
hoping for some help cool man uh pull up
a seat dude what's up
so we recently
divorced
um it was
told you know it's the need to try a
separation and then about so I moved out
of the house and about two weeks later
she told me she was filing for divorce
why what happened what led to that
foreign
I don't really know I've asked several
times I was told there's uh she was
seeking a sense of Independence she's
always been in relationships she wants
to do life on her own grow on her own
there was I was actually listening to
last caller and I can certainly relate
to a lot of what you guys talked about
you know there was a lot of things that
we didn't discuss out of fear or
um afraid of you know stepping on others
toes so there was a lack of
communication
I've been trying to wrap my head around
what I could have done or what I did
wrong I don't necessarily know it's what
I could have done better because at this
point it doesn't really matter but um
I'm just trying to learn from it can I
tell you this
um I think uh
a friend my friend Randy's pointed this
out to me years ago and it stuck with me
um
I I applied for a job once also like he
did and I was the Lone finalist and they
went with nobody
they just called and said it wasn't the
right fit and I remember thinking good
gosh they would rather have nobody than
me
that was worse than being one of three
finalists and having them pick somebody
else right because like they I don't fit
where you all chose nobody over me
here's why I tell you that
that is super painful
it's one thing if you were abusive or
you screwed up or you cheated on her and
she's I I'm out of here because then you
can point to a thing
it's harder when you are left in a wisp
of smoke
and here's what I want to caution you
against I know we haven't gotten into
the end of the call I want you to
caution you against trying to get inside
her head and figure out why she did what
she did
the fact that she left your marriage and
left you standing there and Can't Tell
You Why
is all you need to know about the
caliber of person you're working with
here
it's a person who's entirely inward
focused on themself and themselves only
and that's devastating and heartbreaking
because she chose nothing over you and
that's hard and you just gotta grieve
the crap out of it
is that fair
yes sir I've been been trying to work
through the The Grieving I've been
allowing myself times throughout the day
to good when it when it hits me to cry
get angry good you know and process this
stuff and I've been I've been sticking
close to my
my support group and they've been
awesome
um I've also been isolating and eating
which is another side of it it's uh
I just at this point I feel like I've
got
I no longer have uh Direction
on what to do in life like just a quick
backstory or whatever history is
when we got together
um we drink together heavily a lot and
then six years ago you know next month
God willing all six years sober we got
sober so
we've been you know ups and downs and
have gotten through the first years
already it was very interesting in our
household I bet man
because you know both of us you know I I
can say I'm you know I'm an alcoholic
and
I said Thank God next next month you
know God willing off six years sober so
I've had a lot of stuff to work through
and that's what I thought if we could
get through that kind of stuff you know
there's and we can get through anything
and those were the discussions that we
had
and it was rough but it seemed like
everything had gotten better and
you know for a long time I had alcohol
as my distraction and whatever other
substances and then that went away and
then I kind of had my wife is my
distraction and my husband is as my
identity and now that's been taken away
and it's like
I just I feel lost I feel like right now
and I'm in the process of trying to find
a new home so it's like to start a new
life or start life over I guess and I
just kind of feel like I'm in purgatory
right now just kind of waiting in this
in between it's like I want to heal and
move forward
maybe I'm trying to rush it I don't know
but it's like I'm just so stuck without
Direction I have no idea what I like to
do I don't know what happened yeah
so I'll I'll tell you this you're not
going to like my answer but you're right
where you need to be
you're not crazy okay you're not crazy
and you're not broken or dysfunctional
or you aren't the guy whose wife walked
out on him
who's also wrestling with sobriety and
um
who feels lost
you are surrounded by a cloud of
witnesses my brother okay
you're not crazy
um in these moments when everything feel
like you feel completely untethered from
every you were unhooked from love you
were unhooked From Desire you're
unhooked from safety you're unhooked
from your ride or die you're unhooked
right
yes you have opened your eyes up on the
plains of Kansas and your tribe left you
okay
these are actually the worst times to
get existential
because your body's in fight or flight
this is the best time to make a list a
very detailed list of little wins and
get through every day
and what you're going to find is I will
wake up at this time I will go to work I
will exercise I will call go to my group
I will not miss a meeting you don't care
if you've not been in a while I'm gonna
start going to meetings again I will
call my sponsor I will eat somewhat
reasonably I will go shoot pool and hang
out whatever the thing is and then that
day's over and then I'm gonna get up and
I'm gonna do it again I'm gonna get up
and I'm gonna do it again and what
you're gonna find in 30 days 60 days 120
days is the light starts coming back on
what most people do is they sit in that
in that black hole and they wait for the
light to come back on and it never does
see what I'm saying yes sir I wish there
was a way to think your way out of where
you are and there's not
you have to act
and that's the worst when that black
curtain Falls right
yes sir and let me tell you this stop
saying God willing
don't drink
is that cool
yes I know that's part of the language
and I know that's part of the thing but
I want you just to say I'm not drinking
yeah it's there's nothing worth it going
back to that no miserable life oh
you are not who you once were man
so let me ask you this crazy I just said
don't get existential but
what like
drop your shoulders for a second and
just like free flow with me for a minute
like who do you want to be
and not profession wise I'm talking
about like you want to be a guy that
laughs a lot you want to be a guy that
like people think is a is a hunk you
want to be a guy that can fix stuff like
who do you want to be
I mean you kind of just nailed it right
on the head I mean I just I enjoy
I'm finally getting to a point where I
you know enjoy life and
I like riding motorcycles I like working
on
uh engines and just doing stuff with my
hands and
yeah it's nice being a sober productive
member of society
but beneath that you know what it's what
it's even nicer
deciding what you want and deciding what
you need and then going to make that
happen
and when you are doing if you were your
needs are being met and you're doing
things that you love
all of us in society benefit
what you've been doing for a long time
you nailed it on the head you traded
alcoholism for codependency you traded
alcohol addiction for love addiction
yes and that's cool I mean it's a it's a
better addiction right it's at least
it's a lot it's it but it's it's
exposing right You're vulnerable because
now when love Cuts themself off from you
or unplugs from you man
you're back to you're back to day what
is it what's the what's what's the death
day is it day 15 day 16
um those first 30 days when you're like
I can't make this and you're like going
minute by minute remember those days
that's where you are right now
yes
having to look at myself in the mirror
and be okay with with who's there no
distractions yeah man that's that's the
worst man right
so here's what we're gonna do over time
we're gonna build a life that includes
Joy and we're gonna build a life that
includes love again because you will and
you're going to build a life full of
friends and community
but not today
is about grief
and today's about reconnecting with
people
and today is about doing today the best
you can and tomorrow you can do tomorrow
the best you can
and for you it's going to be both
it's cool because you've walked this
path before
and it's in some ways it's like the
person who lost 50 pounds and gained
back 60 and now they're going on a diet
again
it's so frustrating you gotta walk this
road again but here you are
is that fair
yes sir it's just annoying that you got
to do it again
but let me ask you this What alternative
do you got
none I'm not going back to that yes sir
other life
can I ask you this are you good man
yes
you're a good guy
yes you treat people well
yes you tip well at the restaurants
yes you pick up a toilet seat when
you're in a public restroom
yeah with my shoe but yeah yeah I don't
care what don't do it don't do it in
their mouth yeah don't do with your
hands weirdo yeah do it with your feet
that's how I do it too
yeah man you're a good guy
and when you look in the mirror you
don't have to be like I like you I don't
always like myself but I do have to be
honest and say I'm a good guy
doing the best I can with the hand that
got dealt and now it's time to
play another way or learn a new thing or
to get a little bit better at this thing
or to but that starts with falling a
path man so what's tomorrow going to
look like for you
I can lay it out for me you're gonna
wake up and then what
um
normal is routine is just waking up uh
getting a cup of coffee and getting
ready for work
afterward I've been
getting back into the gym so
do that immediately after work before I
get distracted with anything else
otherwise I'll talk myself out of it oh
dude will you commit to not missing for
30 days straight
yes promise
yes we have like 16 and a half listeners
and I say half because I think
somebody's got a kid that listens so the
accountability Is Not Great Seth but you
just told everybody for 30 days and on
the days that you don't go lift heavy
because you don't you don't do that back
to back just go ride the bike for 10
minutes do something but just commit I'm
gonna do something because I'm worth
doing something or I'll go for a walk in
my neighborhood but I'm gonna do
something for every day for 30 days is
that fair
I can do that yes will you reach out to
somebody every day for 30 days call a
friend
absolutely promise
yes are you back in meetings
oh yeah yeah actually they have
increased substantially absolutely it's
been a great thing good dude you are
uh I hate to tell you this you were in
the right place
and I know that doesn't I I hate to tell
you that because it doesn't make the
hurt go away right now
um you miss her huh absolutely
but I also you know the more I process
this and kind of like you had touched on
earlier it's like
you know I had
set expectations that or uh maybe
Concepts or thoughts you know
of the person
who she is and you know people change
and grow and you know my expectations
aren't weren't being met and that's
um you know that's something I'm dealing
with but maybe she's not the person I
thought I don't I don't know I can't I
it's something it sounds clear to me
that she's not who you thought she was
yeah or that in the same way you weren't
didn't have the skills to articulate
here's what I need here's what I want
and here's what I'm missing and here's
where I'm scared here's where I feel
alone yes she didn't have those same
skills either
and the the demon beneath communication
you know every marriage thing is I gotta
communicate you got to communicate
beneath that is
feeling completely alone in a bed you
share with somebody
right
and the human need for connection is too
great it will it will be met somewhere
or in some way all I have to say is this
stay out of her head you're never going
to get a clear answer she may not have a
clear answer as to why she felt like she
had to go
stay in your head
and in the head of your friends and
those who said I'll stick with you I'll
keep riding with you Seth which may be
your immediate guys at your meeting by
the way the meeting's talking about this
AAA meetings
um the guys that you're meeting or
celebrate recovery meetings
um the guys at your meetings your
friends your counselor whoever that
happens to be your buddies at work
whatever that looks like
um
ride with him I'd also recommend dude
two things go to Walmart this afternoon
or Walgreens or Target or whatever buy a
cheap little
journaly thing like I got here you
should probably have one of those um if
you've been doing a for a while and get
a deck of cards like uh like note cards
it's like okay a dollar and just commit
for 30 days I'm gonna write down here's
what I'm gonna do today I'm gonna wake
up and have coffee I'm going to meditate
for one minute I'm gonna write five
things I'm grateful for I'm gonna get to
work five minutes early so I don't I'm
not rushed and crazy I'm gonna go to the
gym write those things down and mark
them off and all we're doing is we're
winning every day that's it we're gonna
win the day and then go to the next win
the day go to the next is that fair yeah
yes sir brother I'm I'm I I can hear I'm
heartbroken with you
I'm heartbroken with you
my promise is if you take care of the
little days and you're honest about your
feelings over the next five six months
the light will come on so bright you'll
you'll laugh at how clear the path head
is
okay but you gotta take care of the
little days
you can do that is that cool
yes sir absolutely hey I'm I'm as proud
of you as I've been anybody in a long
long time
thank you uh
you're walking through life dragging a
heavy sled behind you pretty good pretty
impressive
[Music]
is that fair yes sir absolutely cool
cool at some point
you can take that sled off you're gonna
walk free you're gonna walk clear
you'll you'll stand about six inches
taller that's not today
is a day to grieve and be sad and be
with your brothers sorry my man sorry
we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement in MLS ID 1591 nmls
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only not available in all
states or locations
all right we are back let's go to
Madeline
back to Kansas City we're going to
Kansas City but on the Missouri side
what's up Madeline yes hey how are you
you're like don't don't ever loot me in
with Kansas absolutely not people think
the Civil War is going to be between New
York and L.A it's super not it's going
to be Missouri versus Kansas that's
where it's going to start 100
so thanks for having me listen don't
fight Kansas they're great I love kids
all right so what's up
so um I'm calling today because
um I was just curious navigating dating
in 2022
um how do you balance contentment and
singleness while longing for a life
partner
I'm an old married guy I don't know I
know you tell me
so I'm almost 30 years old and I've
never dated what let me stop you how
come
it's just never presented itself no no
why haven't you dated
honestly have never been asked but
something I've struggled with is
reaching out and trying to find
connection but often being met with
rejection or ghosting so it's like
trying to initiate that just to even
have basic connection and not even with
the intent of like I'm gonna marry you
but just trying to you know become
friends and be connected and have those
relationships but it's it has just been
um a dead end and I am just kind of in a
rut and
kind of lost so I need some guidance
yeah
I think beneath you you're smiling while
you're talking because that's what you
do
um
I can hear it in you
yeah it's it's like you've got the same
you got this thing duct tape together
is that fair
yes
so let me get behind the
people just ghost me behind the nobody's
ever asked me
beneath all of that
somebody told Madeline that Madeline's
not worth hanging out with
Madeline's not beautiful enough anyone
would ever kiss her
nobody will find Madeline this or nobody
to find that
what has here's what I'm getting at I
see young kids
that maniacally insert themselves into
groups of people that they were not
invited to because they're just Reckless
they don't have any concept that they
might not be valued or wanted
and then I look at listen to you you
already have made me laugh you're super
articulate you're able to identify what
you're going through and cover it up
like
you're clearly
brilliant
how do you get there but you are missing
the
people don't want me around
right where does that come from
I don't know
anything recently because I I'm a huge
fan of yours I'm reading through your
book currently I'm almost finished with
it and it's just I it's phenomenal
um
but I've just kind of been soaking up
you know your stuff like a sponge and
just trying to apply that and I think
reflecting back like I had kind of
an uneasy childhood as far as like I
have a phenomenal family great support
system
um but
school age years
I struggled with weight I still struggle
with it a little bit
um but that's always kind of been
a piece I guess in it and
is your struggle with appearance
something that's been noted on you or is
that something that you bring to a group
or bring to another person
um
it's something I just kind of keep
inward I I don't really like to reflect
it outward but I guess
um maybe it does not sure let me say it
this way I'll give you an example for my
life okay
um I dated somebody when I was in high
school somebody that was madly wildly in
love with for all a 16 year old or 18
year old I don't know how old it was
could be in love right I don't know what
that meant but I was and I'll never
forget one time we were hanging out and
we were holding hands and then she like
on she loosened up her hand and ran it
up the inside of my arm and was holding
the inside of my arm that that meant we
were like you know like we're really
close to babies right I mean like we're
in love right right and she looked up at
me and said
you would be so cute and remember back
back when I was in school acute mint
smoking hot right she was like you would
be so cute if your teeth weren't so
yellow
and so that was years ago that's a
little bitty thing
to this day I still smile
with my mouth shut
I take pictures for a living
right I'm being videoed right now and I
smile with my mouth shut and more
importantly I'm very awkward in person
and my wife pointed this out to me a few
times over our years together
uh-huh um she said I'll walk into a
situation and then I'll lean back
and I mumble because I keep my mouth
closed all the time but I talk so much
that I just in this mumbling stream of
Jo here's the thing all of that is my
insecurity from a 16 year old girlfriend
in reality I got yellow teeth they're
not sparkly white like my friend Rachel
my friend George like they open their
mouth and it's blinding right I don't
have that I'm not that right
um and
I have taken my insecurity in that area
and I just throw it like a cast net over
everybody in my in my vicinity
and so I bring my insecure to other
people and what my wife has told me is
it's unnerving because people see you
John they see me and they think that
guy's cool that guy does this he's got a
good job he's like this why is he so
weird around me it must be me and then
they back up because they don't want to
be the weird person
okay see what I'm saying
yeah so it might not be you the person
who thinks that they don't look right or
that they're not beautiful enough
and it might be
she acts super weird around me and I
think she's pretty Rad or she's
hilarious or I think she's beautiful
but I feel weird around her you see what
I'm saying that's the difference between
walking into a situation and saying I'm
freaking Madeline from Missouri
I deserve to be in every space I walk
into and if you don't want to be in that
space with my big smile
and my whatever I look like then you are
free to go and that's on you not on me
and that's a completely different
composite than I have a crush on you and
I want to date you but I know that I'm
not as pretty as I think I could be for
you and so I'm just gonna try to get
really small
see how different that is
right
I'm sorry yeah
no I I you you've just articulated I
think I think a lot of oceans and like a
little hamster wheel of thoughts in my
in my mind
so the best way out of off the hamster
wheel is not more thinking it's doing
right and that's the worst it's the
worst
yes right so uh I'll tell you I'll tell
you this story and then we can we can
try to come up with a solution or a
couple of solutions we can't solve it I
I it would be it would be dishonest and
disingenuous of me to be like all right
here's how you date in the 21st century
I don't know here's what I do know
um a buddy of mine got divorced a few
years ago and we're out to lunch and I
was kind of living vicariously through
him I was like all right dude you're
dating again like what's it like I'll
never forget we were like in some burger
joint in Texas
and he takes the sets his food down and
he wipes his wipes his mouth off and he
leaned in across the table and he said I
don't care how bad it gets at your house
man never never never never break up you
gotta stay together man this crazy out
here and I was like what do you mean he
goes it's insane everybody's nuts and he
went on to explain like remember when
you would meet somebody like a church or
at a bar or something and you'd say hi
and get their number now they call the
police if you do that he goes exactly
it's stalking you can't do that you have
to follow them on the internets for a
while and anyway he just is like a whole
new planet opened up so my first thought
is to date in the 21st century you
should probably take uh online
programming class maybe that would help
like interact with the internet I don't
know
um here's here's a more truthful answer
I think you need to practice being
around people and catching yourself when
you start to feel awkward or not a part
of the group
okay and when you feel yourself begin to
lean back when you feel yourself I laugh
too loud
I don't look good in this shirt
begin to really challenge those thoughts
is this true
okay could you stand to lose weight
probably possibly
right I could right
is that the reason nobody loves you no
it's not
is that the reason why you're single no
it's not
okay okay
there's something behind that that means
you're gonna have to spend a season
being weird and uncomfortable which is
probably the two things you spent your
life avoiding
being the weird one and the
uncomfortable one is that fair
yes okay expect rejection expect failure
expect crash and burns expect to lean in
and kiss somebody and then be like what
are you doing or expect somebody to lean
and kiss you and their breath is so bad
your eyebrows fall out expect all those
things misreading signals all of that
okay you've never done it so you got to
be graceful with yourself
and there are a few people on the planet
who have made more dating mistakes than
I have I was the worst at it I was the
most clueless [ __ ] I just didn't see I
just didn't
and I just kept getting back up and
going again
mostly because I was too stupid to know
what he did to know what he did
so when I'd say
ask folks out have a regularly a regular
weekly gathering at your house with a
couple of strangers or people from work
or people from your local church or
people from the Y I don't care
tell me what that does in your body
cultivate that and have people over and
host and do the things okay but
um
I guess maybe I do it in a safe manner I
do it with the people that I've known
the longest and but I'm closest to but
um are you gonna date any of them
no
so that's here's what that's like that's
like you
um going to a pond on your granddad's
farm and uh because I just assume
everybody in Missouri has a farm and you
know there's no fish in there but that
is the pond that makes you the most
comfortable and then you just cast your
line in there and sit all day and you're
like I'm terrible at fishing fish don't
like me that's not true you just know
that that's your that's your ride or die
group that's not your romance group
right is that fair
yes so you gotta be weird okay where do
we go to meet the people
go first bring them to you
bring them to you
invite five or six people from work over
and and this is gonna sound ridiculous
but what we're doing is we're practicing
being awkward
okay we're practicing not overdoing it
when it comes to I'm trying to to alter
my appearance so that I can feel like I
am fill in the blank
we're just going to be you you're going
to practice not cleaning up your house
and making it look like it's an HDTV
reveal every time somebody walks over to
your house
you're gonna practice feeling
comfortable and loved in your own skin
okay is that fair
yes that's very fair you called me out
on the HGTV
but all that all that is that's just
make up for your home
that's an extra large shirt to cover up
your body for your home
that is saying no to something that you
really want to go to because you just
feel like you're not having a pretty day
and then blaming them for not calling
you again after they've been rejected a
few times by you
is that fair
that's 100 fair and and and because I
can hear the people on the internet
screaming too
you may have to address your health
and yeah
issues but that's something that's a
priority okay for me make that priority
because you're worth a life where your
knees don't hurt and your back doesn't
hurt and you don't have headaches all
the time not to get somebody to sleep
with you
you see the direction the difference
there
one is maniacal and pathological and
chasing a moving Target that you can
never catch one is looking in the mirror
and smiling
you see the difference
yes
let's be healthy let's take care of
ourselves let's be a good Steward of our
bodies because Madeline's worth a really
fun awesome life
not because she wants to hook up with
Dan Dan's the worst Madeline you know
is that fear
yes it's fair okay
become the best version of you you can
be and okay just go be weird don't be
weird okay
perfect listen will you
um
commit to going out go being weird for
the next 30 45 days inviting people over
setting up a thing I'm gonna send you
all of the questions for humans cards I
got
oh my gosh thank you so much
of the kids packs the adults pack I'll
send them all okay perfect and I want
you to use them
uh invite people over and say hey we're
gonna play these games and if those
games are lame do do another game just
come over and play games or we're gonna
play Truth or Dare we're gonna play kid
games whatever the thing is
um
let's invite people over and there's
gonna be people like this sucks you're
weird and there's gonna be three or four
people they're like dude that was the
most fun I've had in a long time
and they're gonna cut they're that's
you're gonna find your Rider dies and
they're gonna bring a friend next time
they come and then they're gonna bring
somebody else and then suddenly you're
gonna look across the room and be like
there it is see what I'm saying
but that's from the inside out not the
outside in
okay and if we come to Kansas will you
come to the show
um 100 I'm there oh
I got credible dude it's gonna be a
disco Madeline I can't even wait it's
not on the calendar but I can't even
wait hey
thank you for being brave Madeline I'm
grateful for you we'll be right back
[Music]
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we are back I
so I'm that guy today I went to the
killer show this weekend and can I just
say this
if you have a chance to see The Killers
live in concert
I wish I'd taken my son with me I wish
I'd taken my wife with me she was gonna
go and she didn't go at the last minute
so I ended up taking a buddy
I've been smiling for the last four days
it was such an event of joy and laughter
and just happiness in that show The
Killers Brandon Flowers is a magician on
stage one of the best front men I've
ever seen but I'm that guy because I'm
wearing the shirt like you went to the
show last night yeah I'm that guy and so
I thought they were gonna bring a killer
show in a song in for the day they
didn't they said I mentioned Kansas so
much and so I then thought oh you're
gonna bring Kansas song and they hand me
the Kansas theme song
there's no place like home
there's no place like home the song is
Over the Rainbow by Judy Garland
see what y'all did there that's a deep
cut this is a deep Kansas cut well done
Over the Rainbow and it goes like this
somewhere over the rainbow way up high
there's a land that I heard of once in a
lullaby
Somewhere Over the Rainbow skies are
blue and the dreams that you dare to
dream really do come true someday I'll
wish upon a star and wake up where the
clouds are far behind me where troubles
melt like lemon drops away above the
chimney tops that's where you'll find me
well you'll find me right here
on the internets and on the YouTubes on
the Dr John Delaney show see you soon
[Music]